it's just a form of language it's an art  and a lot of people don't understand  that a lot of people think that you know  oh what's these guys doing with their  hands they were already throwing up gang  signs but no it's the story it's the  whole thing going on  [Music]  basically we're trying to show you  something that's not there that you've  never seen before  bring you into all world because your  whole body is an instrument  [Music]  you  [Music]  I just try and think different just cuz  you see someone else doing it try and do  that but different in a better way you  know take something make it yours  that's really that's how I come up  everything  you